one of the fascinating things about
Bitcoin and sorry to romanticize certain
Notions but Satoshi Nakamoto that the
founder is anonymous
um maybe you can speak to whether that's
useful but also I just like the
psychology of that to imagine that
there's a human being that was able to
create something special and walk away
uh so first are you Satoshi Nakamoto I'm
certain I'm not
um no I actually I you know I think the
provenance is really important and if I
were to look at the highlighted points I
think
having a Founder that was Anonymous or
should Anonymous is important I think
the founder disappearing is also
important I think that the fact that
Satoshi coins never moved is also
important
I think the the lack of an initial coin
offering is also important I think the
lack of a corporate sponsor is important
I think the fact that it traded for 15
months with no commercial value
was also important you know I I think
that um
the Simplicity of the protocol
and is very important I think that the
the outcome of the block size Wars is
very important and all of those things
add up to Common property they're
they're all indicia indicators of a
digital property as opposed to security
if there was a Satoshi sitting around
sitting on top of 50 billion dollars
worth of bitcoin it I don't think it
would um
[ __ ] Bitcoin as property but I think
it would undermine
its digital property and I if I wanted
to undermine a crypto asset Network I
would do the opposite of all those
things I would launch one myself I would
sell 25 or 50 of the general public I
would keep some of the initial I would
pre-mind some stuff or early mine it you
know and I would keep an influence on it
those are all the opposite of what you
would do in order to create common
property
and so I see the entire story as Satoshi
giving a gift
of digital property to the human race
and disappearing do you think it was one
person do you have ideas of who it could
be I don't care to speculate
but do you think it was one person
like it was one person maybe in
conjunction with a bunch of others I
mean it might have been a group of
people that were working together but
certainly the there's a Satoshi and it's
just so fascinating to me that one
person could be so brave and thoughtful
or do you think a lot of his accent like
the block size Wars the decision to make
a block a certain size
all the things you mentioned led up to
the characteristics that make Bitcoin
property
do you think that's an accident or it
was deeply thought through like how does
this is almost like a history of Science
question people tried it for they tried
40 of them right I mean I I think
there's a there's a history of
attempting to create something like this
and it was tried many many times and and
they failed for different reasons and I
think that it's like Prometheus tried to
start a fire 47 times and maybe the 48th
time it sparked and and that's how I see
this this is the first one that's
sparked
and uh and it sets a road map for us and
I and I think
if you're looking for any one word that
characterize it's fair right the whole
point of the network is it's a fair
launch a fair distribution
like yeah
I have Bitcoin but I bought it
in fact I you know at this point we've
paid four billion dollars of you real
cash to buy it if if I was sitting on
the same position and I had it for free
then there's always this question of did
I you know I bought it for a nickel a
coin or a penny a coin the question is
was it fair and and that's a very hard
question to answer right did you acquire
the Bitcoin that you own fairly
and if you roll the clock back you know
you could have bought it for a nickel or
a dime but that was when it was a
million times more likely to fail right
when the risk was greater the cost was
lower and then over time the risk became
lower and the cost became greater and
the real critical thing was to allow the
marketplace absent any powerful
interested actor
right it's almost like if Satoshi had
held a million coins and then stayed
engaged for 10 more years tweaking
things in the background there'd still
be that question
but what we've got is really a beautiful
thing we've got a we've got a chain
reaction in cyberspace or an ideology
spreading virally in the world
that um that has seasoned in a fair
ethical fashion sometimes it's a very
violent brutal fashion with all the
volatility
right and there's been a lot of you know
a lot of Sound and Fury along the way